[Musique]
les inondations de ce printemps vont
marquer notre histoire mais pour
l'instant elles ont surtout marqué les
familles
[Musique]
l'équipe helvète
on a fait cela pour traverser le 4 jours
sur la pointe des orteils propos de ces
massacres
la maison de jesse et marianne n'était
pas en zone inondable et pourtant le
premier soir on est descendant à bord il
y avait 2 pouces d'eau dans la même
forme et entouré d'autres tout ça vient
soit on comprenait pas du cas venez
lourd écoute la panique totale
même les enfants audrey et sont pas trop
planète mongolie joie dans l'eau les
forces vives le chercher à la maison les
premières semaines seront traversées
plus en voiture
des chansons étaient heureux que
désirait aller y compris maintenant à
l'école les peaux problème la garderie
celles fournies
qu'est ce qui s'est passé et la guyane
le tourisme bat qu elle était tombée
était d'un intrus
marianne et ses deux enfants ont trouvé
refuge chez des amis
chanceux parce que la boïenne cours avec
une trampoline que je sais c'est pas
chez toi
la peur mieux qu'on était venu ce matin
et criait vraiment marrer et catherine
planète très complet aidé par quelques
succès ce jugement c'est d'être séparé
la famille comme ça j'ai pas mon bac je
suis normalement bac à ses trousses du
gaz et n'ayez pas la chaussée d'ixelles
c'est que son back up son conjoint jesse
reste dans la maison familiale à
surveiller les pompes ce triste pour toi
parce que quoi qu'en dise que sont pas
nous avons séparé comme ça pour garçons
comprenait pas trop pensé qu'on s'aimait
pu même à la garderie lui-même en a
beaucoup parlé parce que il était très
angoissée par les juges de touche quand
on vient se faire cet emploi loin c'est
un village complet qui est kitsch et
véronique c'est bien coordonne l'aide
psychosociale pour la sécurité civile de
la région laurentides
moi je pense que ça peut être bénéfique
et les enfants c'est pour qu'ils
comprennent un peuple c'est quoi qui se
passe là entre aide aussi à
on peut apporter aussi une forme d aide
pour réussir on les a envoyés par des
poches de sang avec marianne illégaux de
l'armée pour leur remettre un peu en
voulez pas comprendre ce qu'ils
voulaient des papas puis vous fait pas
est défectueux au talent et la voix
pendant une heure de temps les doigts
avoir fait des parités de seconde lt lt
le jeudi prend des pauses non je vais
des papiers fait une place à 8 euros
s'est fait du bien justin est déporté
c'est ça la tête la longère de porter sa
puissance et
[Musique]
jesse m'amène faire un tour dans le
quartier nous allons à la rencontre de
stéphane lallemand et manon boucher une
autre famille sinistrée
grâce à l'entr'aide des voisins et amis
et après avoir rempli des centaines de
sacs de sable
leur maison a été sauvée c'était
émouvant
puis juste avant l'arrivée des autres
cafés pour tout le monde
gpu l'épuisement qu'il décourage les
jeunes ont une épaisseur sont dans une
période héroïque donc qui font tout pour
sauver leur maison qui mobilise toute
leur énergie pour faire le maximum pour
leurs maisons après ça dans la deuxième
phase qu'on a vécu ce qu'on aperçoit une
période qui est un peu plus de la france
où l'eau se retirer graduellement le
beau temps est arrivé des gens peu on
peut respirer un petit e
[Musique]
manon et ses enfants ont été relogés par
la croix rouge dans un hôtel de saint
géraud c'est quand même bien les enfants
sont vraiment vraiment vraiment un rôle
pour résoudre les vacances de rêve
qu'elle manque le cercueil du vendredi
au mardi moi j'ai l'impression que c'est
une seule journée qui a passé puis
interminables et puis l'énergie est
complètement ap le sait il y en ait plus
la sécurité civile a envoyé psychologues
et travailleurs sociaux sur le terrain
pour aider les sinistrés
elle nous explique les symptômes qui est
nous dit vraiment que c'est normal qu'il
faut vraiment les s'évacuer il faut
vraiment comme c'est un choc nerveux
dans le fond c'est un stress
intense parce que nous on n'a rien perdu
jeudi j'ai pas à plein de ce sommet
c'est le l'adrénaline le stress c'est de
voir tout le monde autour qui ont tout
perdu à tour de rôle puis l'énergie
qu'on avait besoin pour se battre qui
fait que tu dis mon dieu
ça voudrait dire c'est pas normal ce qui
s'est passé piétons corps réagit à sa
personne a des difficultés de sommeil la
personne et terry table des hommes
davantage de la difficulté à vaquer à
ses occupations quotidiennes celles à ce
moment là qu'on doit qu'on doit lever le
drapeau puis aller chercher de lyme est
beaucoup plus spécialisés jesse a
nettoyé et décontaminer le sous sol
nous l'avons retrouvé avec sa famille
une semaine plus tard il y avait une
belle journée garderie à l'école temps
limité ou se reconnaît plus non limoli
des comme ça ici ok bah ouais ce que tu
dors maintenant c'est ici ouais c'est
mon frère yves arabe avec ses jeux de
mourir excuses peu je mange un rat
ok donc à vous dormez tous les deux
ensemble ouais
comment ça se passe c'est bien mais je
skie nice qu au contraire
[Musique]
on est revenu à la maison qui ont passé
toute la journée à faire du vélo d'un
bout de quartier alors au pire or ça
faisait tellement du bien de l'étang de
la maison le même c'est bordélique
l'homme
ils y ont retrouvé leurs amis de trois
options pierre la vie de nos malheurs
est violent
[Musique]